In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadium for July 7th, on which we commemorate, the holy martyr,
Kediaki, during Diocletian's reign, a devout and affluent Christian couple, Dorothios
and Eusebia, who were childless, begged God to give them offspring, promising to consecrate
the child to him.
Their prayer was heard, and they had a daughter on a Sunday, and therefore called the child Kediaki.
Having her baptized, they brought her up in the nurture and admonition of the Lord,
and faithful to their promise preserved her virginity in order to consecrate her to the
Lord's service.
One day, a wealthy pagan who lived in the town, having heard reports of the beauty and
morals of the young virgin, decided to marry her to his son.
But when he went to suggest this to her, Kediaki told him that she was espoused to Christ,
and that she wished to die in virginity.
The noblemen, in a fury, went and announced both her and her parents to emperor Diocletian,
as rebels against his authority.
The sovereign summoned them and asked them why they rejected the gods of the empire.
Dorothios replied courageously that he had learned from his parents to worship the one
and only God, creator of heaven and earth, who was incarnate for our salvation.
He was thrashed.
But as under the blows, he continued to mock the idols, the emperor, seeing that he was
gaining nothing more, sent him and Ocevia to justice, the governor of Mitelini, in little
Armenia.
Dorothios put them to torture and conferred on them the crown of martyrdom by beheading
them.
As for St. Kediaki, Diocletian sent her to his son-in-law, Caesar Maximian, who lived in
Nicomedia.
Having admired her dazzling beauty, Maximian summoned her and told her that he would marry
her to one of the emperor's kinsmen, if she would be willing to honor the gods.
But the frail girl remained inflexible and told him that nothing could separate her from
the love of Christ.
The tyrant then had her pegged out on the ground and ordered that she be beaten to death with
ox sinews.
The exhausted soldiers were changed three times, but the saint remained insensible to the
blows and was only the more radiant with grace.
Maximian, believing that his men out of pity for the young virgin, were not using all their
strength, turned his wrath on them.
The saint then addressed him.
Don't fool yourself, Maximian.
You will never overcome me, as God is here to help me.
Fearing that he would once more be an object of ridicule, the emperor had her taken to
Illadion, governor of Bethinia, a man known for his cruelty towards Christians.
Being read the letter from Maximian that accompanied the captive, Illadion threatened the saint
with unheard of tortures.
Kiriaki replied that it would be easier to damp down fire than to make her submit, and when
they passed flaming tortures over her body after having hung her up by her hair, she remained
impassable, as though she were already clothed in the incorruption promised to the elect.
The following night Christ visited her in the prison, healing her, and promising to deliver
her from all the trials by his grace.
In the morning, the tyrant was amazed to see her unheard, but ascribing this miracle to
the gods, he had her taken to the idol temple.
On going into the temple, the saint knelt and prayed to Christ.
The building immediately collapsed and the idols fell to the ground, breaking into a thousand
pieces that a violent wind dispersed, and the pagans who were present were put to flight.
Illadion, alone, was continuing to blaspheme when a light clothed the sky and burned the
governor's face, and falling from his seat, he expired.
He was replaced by another magistrate called Apolonios, who having been informed of the events
that were troubling the province summoned the saint before him, and condemned her to be
burned alive.
After having lit a great furnace, the soldiers threw Kiryaki in.
She remained for several hours in prayer.
Her hands raised to heaven, without the flames burning her in the least.
As it was summertime and the sky was clear, a black cloud appeared, and a contrary wind
put out the fire.
Apolonios then ordered that two lions be let loose on her, but as soon as they went up to
her, the beasts became as gentle as lambs, and lay down at the saint's feet.
Many pagans who had been witnesses of these prodigies then confessed Christ and were immediately
executed.
On the following day, a further interrogation before the governor also proved useless, realizing
then that he would not be able to overcome Christ's valiant athlete with either flattery
or torture, Apolonios condemned her to death by the sword.
Taken out of the town, the saint asked the executioners to allow her a moment for prayer.
According to her knees, she addressed a long prayer to Christ, who had given her the strength
to witness to his name before kings and princes, and who had preserved her virginity to the
day of her mystical marriage.
Bright angels came to take her soul and presented to her spouse, and she sank gently to the ground.
The soldiers who were preparing to behead her were astounded at finding her already dead.
They then heard a voice from heaven, saying, brethren, go and tell everyone about God's wonders.
While they were on their way to give an account of all they had seen to the governor,
some Christians who had remained hidden for fear of the pagans took the saint's body
and buried it in a worthy place, giving thanks to God.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.